it's certainly heartbreak that no parent
should ever have to go through the loss
of a child back in september a local
mother lost her 14 year old son to a car
crash north las vegas police say that
driver was impaired but now she wants to
honor his memory mary jane bellies live
this morning at lake mead and walnut
with details on her message mary jane
good morning
good morning to you john now this
intersection of lake mead and walnut
near pecos and lamb is a painful
reminder for markeisha davis it's where
her son vernon curry's junior's life was
cut short davis says her son was on his
way to school at desert pines but he
never made it now to honor his memory on
this month which what should have been
his 15th birthday she has a message for
drivers to slow down pay attention to
your surroundings and never drink and
drive it could cost your life and
someone else's
you're not going to get there no faster
slow down you can take a life and
you don't know what you're doing to
other people's family that guy bailed
out and
like what he's done to me and my family
he will never know what he took
because nothing it didn't impact his
life like my 40 year old son died and he
was excited for school he wanted to go
to the army like
he had a bright future
now davis hopes her message will
resonate with you this morning and make
an impact on drivers now at the time of
his death she says that he was just 14
starting his year as a freshman she says
he was excited for high school and
wanted to be a nurse and join the army
reporting live here from lake mead and
walnut mary jane villasa live local now